unfortunately in my lifetime the funding
of public higher education has gone down
dramatically so for instance when I was
a university student at UCLA I could
work a summer job and pay fees and room
and board and books for the rest of the
year my father had five kids they all
went to public institutions he never had
to pay anything now in the US students
have to assume the responsibility for
their higher education themselves they
go into tremendous debt there's a
trillion-dollar debt just owed to
educational institutions in the u.s.
that just didn't exist when I was a
growing up and I think this is a
wholesale change in the political
atmosphere that is I think really
damaging and so I feel very strongly
about this and as a result the one
action that I could do as I've donated
my Nobel prize money for the creation of
endowed chair at my institution so that
we can be as competitive as the private
institutions and bringing the best young
scholars to Berkeley